his name is Rio and he watches from the
stands was her football fans greeted Rio
Ferdinand when he was banned for missing
a drugs test some football chants are
made up on the spot some of a code
around the same grounds for generations
but scientists think they're a practice
that has deep groups in human culture
every social group ever studied from the
maori hacker to the sufi whirling
dervishes to awkward British people at a
wedding engages in some form of groups
singing dancing and chanting why is this
psychologists have found that when a
group of people engage in collective
behavior like chanting it has a profound
effect on how they think and feel group
singing 'he's been shown to have a
powerful effect on the mood of depressed
people as well as the uplifting music it
seems that synchronizing your breathing
heart rate and voice with other people
has the remarkable effect of making us
feel connected to one another for of
course football fans don't usually feel
connected to everyone in the stadium
there are plenty of examples of football
chants that are rou defensive even
racist or homophobic though they've
historically been a means to abused
players and referees they can also
endorse more positive values like
celebrating strike and masalas goals
with a feast Gazza nor the few there now
the Muslim so collective behaviour like
chanting is more than anything a way to
express social identity and the values
of that group like the Liverpool fans
chanting justice for the 96 in support
of the Hillsborough disaster victims
chanting at a football match doesn't
just bond a group together in love and
harmony there is a dark side to
coordinated behavior most armies around
the world march up and down in parades
for the past 100 years at least since
the invention of the machine gun it's
been a bad idea to walk slowly towards
the enemy in a straight line so why do
soldiers march and chant together in one
experiment people were asked to put a
jar of live would license who have
Grindr the people who'd marched in
unison around the carpark beforehand
through about 50% more of the bugs into
the
Grindr than those who'd walked the same
distance but not in a coordinated March
please note there was actually an escape
shift in the grinder and every book
escaped unharmed this suggests
coordinated behaviors can lower people's
sense of personal autonomy and make them
more likely to be obedient to aggressive
action and there is a final reason that
people might hunter a football match
rioting has only been around for a few
thousand years but we find champs and
songs in every preliterate culture even
today in India
it's the chanted version of the Vedic
texts that seem as the definitive
version not the written form perhaps
chanting is a callback to those older
practices of encoding and sharing
cultural knowledge so next time you hear
a thousand people yelling you don't know
what you do win so the referee remember
that it's because they're bonding with
each other affirming their social
identity and using an ancient technology
to record knowledge and perhaps because
the referee doesn't know what he's doing
you